in this video we're going to familiarize
ourselves
with matter we're think about what
matters about
matter but in particular we're going to
think about a lot of words you'll hear
especially in a chemistry class
and how they might relate to each other
when we're classifying matter
so first let's start with the definition
of matter well a good definition is
anything that has mass and anything that
has volume or takes up three-dimensional
space
is matter it has to do both of these
things mass
you probably have an intuitive sense an
elephant has more mass than a mouse
if we want to get a little more
technical it's related to how hard it is
to
accelerate something now you might be
saying isn't this everything that has
mass and volume
but we have to remind ourselves even
within scientific circles there's many
things
we talk about that don't have both mass
and volume
for example we can think about waves
we could think about energy
and then you could think about things
that have energy or that have wave-like
properties like
light or sound
and all of these things would not be
considered matter
and of course i guess you could even
broaden it to ideas like love
that also would not be matter but i'm
i'm probably going on a bit of a tangent
there
but we're going to stay focused on the
matter side not on the not matter
and the first division of matter is
between
what we could view as pure substances
and mixtures
now a pure substance one way to think
about it is
no matter how small we get any sample we
take and we don't
chemically alter that sample so we're
not doing any chemistry making or
breaking bonds here
if we take a chunk of it you're going to
have consistent chemical properties
you're going to get the same thing once
again assuming
that you're not changing the structure
chemically you're not making or breaking
chemical bonds you can get down to the
microscopic to even the molecular level
and you're going to have the same
properties while in a mixture
that isn't true that if you get close
enough
you're going to get chunks of things
that have different properties
now within pure substances and i'll give
a little bit of a division within
mixtures as well
pure substances can be further
subdivided so here we could have a pure
element
so this is a pure substance that only
has one type of element in it
and this is an example of pure gold and
in reality
it's hard to have an absolute 100
percent pure thing
but most of these gold bars you zero in
you're gonna get a
gold atom there if you zoom in enough it
is
pure gold it is a pure element well what
we have over here
this is pure water now water is still a
pure substance
because you go down all the way to the
smallest level to a molecular level as
long as you are not
chemically altering the water you are
going to
still get the same thing at any scale
but water is made up of different types
of elements
the chemical formula for water every
water molecule has two hydrogens
and one oxygen and so when you have a
pure substance
that has more than one type of element
in its smallest unit that has its
chemical properties
we call that a compound now i also use
this word molecule when i talked about a
water molecule and
sometimes it's confusing when do you use
compound when do you use molecule
and one way to think about it is a
molecule is
anything that has more than one atom
bound together while a compound is a
subset of molecules
that has different types of atoms bound
together so for example
if we're thinking about molecules i'm
drawing a little bit of a
little venn diagram here if we or a set
diagram i should say
examples of molecules could be molecular
hydrogen it has two of the same atom
but they are bonded to each other and so
actually if you had a bunch of h2
molecular hydrogen
that would be a pure element it could be
o2 molecular oxygen
that is a molecule but if we're thinking
about compounds we could think about
h2o that is both a molecule and a
compound all compounds are molecules but
not all of molecules are compounds
if you think about carbon dioxide that
is a compound
it has not only more than one atom but
the atoms are of different
types and of course you can have pure
substances that are neither molecules
nor compounds you could have a situation
like
neon which is a noble gas and it doesn't
like to bond with anything even itself
and so it could just be a free atom so
if you had a bunch of neon together that
could be a pure element it is neither a
molecule
nor a compound now let's go on the other
side of this little taxonomy that we're
creating to mixture
so mixture if a pure substance at any
scale you go down the microscopic scale
and as long as you're not chemically
altering making and breaking bonds
you're going to get the same properties
you're going to get the same stuff
but in a mixture when you get down to a
small scale
you don't necessarily get the same thing
and that you can actually
get different things not by doing
chemical changes but by doing
physical changes to them so this right
over here where you can clearly see the
difference so there it looks like in
this
in this rock here part of it is this one
type of
glassy looking mineral here and then you
have this other type of mineral looking
here
it's clear that these minerals are mixed
together
and a mixture where it's clear that the
different parts are
different stuff we would call this a
heterogeneous mixture
heterogeneous each of these
minerals are oftentimes pure substances
but you have a bunch of pure substances
mixed together but you can
it's pretty easy to pick out where one
is versus the other and they aren't
mixed together in a uniform way
and so that's why we call it a
heterogeneous mixture
now in this picture on the right we have
to have
two mixtures going on we have the
air up here and air itself is a mixture
a lot of you might say wait air is
matter doesn't feel like anything is
there well that's just because that's
just because you're used to it
matter is anything with mass or volume
and air
especially the air molecules for sure
have mass and for sure
take up space they have volume to it
matter can come as a as a gas as a
liquid as a solid
and even as plasma those are all those
are states of matter but that is all
matter
but the reason why the air that we
breathe is considered a mixture
is that it's full of nitrogen it's full
of oxygen
it's full of carbon dioxide in fact it's
it's mostly nitrogen and oxygen
those things can be physically separated
from itself you can
zoom in on the air and you can do things
to just pick out a nitrogen
molecule or an oxygen molecule or a
carbon
dioxide molecule without making or
breaking
bonds but air where you have these
different pure substances that are mixed
together
really well in a uniform way this is
known as a homogeneous mixture
homogeneous and similarly
water that you might see in say the
ocean is also going to be a homogeneous
mixture because it doesn't just have
h2o in it it for sure is going to have
h2o in it but it's also going to have
sodium chloride that has been dissolved
in it so it'll have
sodium ions and chloride anions in it
it's going to probably have other things
that are mixed into it it's probably
going to have molecular
oxygen mixed into it but it's mixed
generally pretty uniformly so that's why
we call it a
homogeneous mixture so i'll let you go
there this is giving you the toolkit for
a lot of the words that you will hear in
chemistry class
and it's useful to be able to know what
these different things mean